YUFENG GUO: I know that you
use debuggers the right way
every time, and would
never use print statements
to debug your code, right?
Because if you did, you might
find that TensorFlow's print
statement doesn't quite work
the same way as typical print
statements.
Today I'll show you how
TensorFlow's print statements
work and how to make
the most of them,
hopefully saving you
some time along the way.
There are a couple ways
to get things to print out
while writing TensorFlow code.
Of course, there's the classic
built-in Python function,
print.
Then there is TensorFlow's
print function,
tf.Print with a capital P.
When working with TensorFlow,
it's important to remember
that everything is ultimately
a graph computation.
This means that if you just use
Python to print a TensorFlow
operation, it will simply
show a description of what
that operation is
since no values have
been passed through it yet.
It will also often
show the dimensions
that are expected to be in
that node if they're known.
If you want to print
the values that
are flowing through a
particular part of the graph
as it's being
executed, then we'll
need to turn to using tf.Print.
Often we think of
print as something
that we add on to the side of
something, just let it run,
and then come back to our
normal flow of operations.
In TensorFlow, only
the nodes of the graph
that need to be executed
will be executed.
So if you have a dangling
print node in your graph,
it won't be executed.
So what are we to do?
We need to splice the print
call into the graph like so.
The way this
manifests in code is
to have the print call
take as its first parameter
the node that is
its input, and then
assign the output
to a variable that
will serve as an input in
a later node in the graph,
thus linking the print
statement serially
into the flow of operations.
While the print statement
does no computation
and just passes
the value onward,
it will print the desired
node as a side effect.
Another behavior that's
a bit unlike what
we're used to seeing
in a print statement
is that the print
node that we introduce
is merely locking in when the
print statement will happen,
namely when the node is reached
in the computational graph.
However, there aren't
really many restrictions
on what you print.
That is, you can print just
about any node in the graph
that you can access.
This is the second argument
to the tf.Print call--
an array of nodes to print.
Often we'll just
use the same node
as the first argument,
which was that input,
but we could include a lot more
nodes in the print statement
if we'd like.
There is also a third argument--
a message.
This will allow you to prepend
some string before printing out
those nodes so you can
easily find a given print
statement in your logs.
So there you have it--
tf.Print in a nutshell.
But where might you utilize
tf.Print in your code?
I often find myself using
tf.Print in my input functions
to debug exactly what's being
passed into my training.
Merely using the Python print
is not quite enough here
since it will only print once--
when the input function
graph is constructed.
So instead, we'll
introduce the tf.Print call
into the input
function's data pipeline.
Notice that we are just
printing the same value
that we passed in as the
input, but you could certainly
print other nodes in
this array as well.
A word of caution here--
if you use tf.Print in
your input function,
be sure to set
some kind of limits
around the amount of data
that you're passing in.
Otherwise, you may end up
with a really long log file.
There are many ways in which
TensorFlow's print statement is
not your typical
print statement,
but it can be used
to great effect
when you need to see the
tensors flowing in your graph.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
Be sure to subscribe
to the channel
to catch future episodes
right when they come out.
And for now, go see how
TensorFlow's print statements
can help you get more
clarity into how your machine
learning is running.